emily drake has been trying to help kids
working on farms in north carolina many
of them are not even 14 years old
most of them come from latin america and
work in the u.s illegally they work up
to 14 hours a day and get paid a
pittance
that's something that emily drake hopes
to change she's appealing to lawmakers
in
congress we aim to end child
exploitation in agriculture and equalize
the child labor law every child deserves
an equal
right to an education and to to being a
kid
healthy and protected
celia ortiz knows this world she arrived
in the usa with her parents when she was
just a baby she started working in the
tobacco fields when she was 11.
you don't have water with you because
you have to wait sometimes you're out
the road and you start feeling um
nauseous dc you really feel like you're
gonna die like the feeling is so
horrible you feel like you're about to
go out part of the reason celia along
with ngos and trade unions regularly
inform lawmakers on the conditions on
u.s farms
at least half a million children harvest
the crops there
and one of the things that children are
doing right now in the fields is working
with tobacco children who were too young
to buy cigarettes are cultivating and
harvesting tobacco and literally being
poisoned by nicotine
as they cultivate tobacco the members of
congress listened to the women for two
hours the experience left emily and
celia cautiously optimistic
i think the hearing went very well uh
many very important points were made um
the event was well attended and now it's
up to the folks who were in the room to
take that information and and actually
do something about it
if the status quo continues as it has
done for years they want to take their
case to washington they think it's
scandalous that child labour is still
tolerated in one of the richest
countries in the world